bad news Wall Street is unanimous in
expecting growth is low in 2023 maybe
even a recession the good news economic
pain might just be what stops the
Federal Reserve from Raising interest
rates further which would bring much
needed relief to markets for much of
2022 good economic news such as a strong
labor market had allowed the FED to
deliver the most aggressive rate hikes
in decades that in turn has led to
Historic losses in both stocks and bonds
this year some investors are expecting
the FED to slow its rapid pace of
tightening and perhaps even pivot to
consider rate cuts for markets that
means an uneven year of trading for
instance Deutsche Bank expects the S P
500 to Rally in the first half of the
year before falling 25 in the third
quarter only to bounce back by year end
as for bonds there's growing consensus
on their recovery especially if the FED
slows down on rate hikes a Monday Asset
Management says bonds are back and
valuations are more attractive and few
are bothering with crypto most banks
excluded the asset class from their 2023
outlooks entirely after a collapse in
digital assets
[Music]